分享三个我从12年游动机
到现在素颜量量好状态
一直在坚持喝的开火
黑养书果汁配方
如果你跟我之前一样
非常的爱掌豆腝是安全和容易变弈的话
就一定要试试
这几块是我常了很多种搭配之后
试出来比较好和口感比较好的
不需要你呃
这喝第一个是哈佛将银硬
口味改良饭
三服天的话就特别适合喝谈
用到了身疆灵梦梦里和苹果
灵梦两片去子流皮
我试过刘银梦皮很不流的
我还是觉得口感流着会更清晰一些
身疆是强力开普适环的
我一般会切个一两片
然后身疆皮我会流着
一起吃就没有那么容易上火
苹果放一半
增加一点甜度和线路味
是口心会更好一些
中理方半个就好
它里面有丰富的
善视线味
所以会让人很通常
一点点的肉贵粉中和调时过的含气
味道也会更丰富一些
在家两百好深的清水
就这么打在一起不要过努力
早上来一杯一整天
都会感觉特别轻松提升型腦
对水种和暗沉特别有效
而且真的很通常
第二个我给他请您叫满杯花轻素
用到的食材有这些
阿轻素的K-O話能力是VC的时辈以上
中安公分有几
K-U 不互一百专
对我们的眼睛也非常好
像这几个里面就是满满的花轻素
你梦会放两片去子代皮
那说我读的水果比例
一定不能太多
不然糖分会太高
除了这些食材
我还会加一些其他子
屋渡游和有几十五蛋白
因为这个我是早上做代餐的
需要有一些拥振的脂肪和宝负感
阿轻没粉丝公认的
可以要化网者
我们来一小少
再加一点点的肉贵和姜晃
它不会影响口感
但是可以增加可以
到果然请帮我们中和一些水果的含气
黑滚姜加在这里是提升姜晃素的吸收力的
再加255小时的清水一起打
这一杯下去真的感觉皮膚要亮成小燈泡了
第三杯是大力水熟小率
这个我一般也是做早上的代餐的
又到时才有真心
游游果可以提供游质的
只防喝回生素一雪离亲热温费
还可以增加一些清甜解游游果的逆
于干栏和生菜
就是生律色素菜的代表
富汗夜律素和框物质和看化物质
还有搭配的屋渡游和粉粉
可以一起供丰负的游质质
我们敢三和蛋白
这一杯超级亲热的喝起来口感很像哪些
清藏排骨
给皮膚深层不水
还可以稳定食育
秋天也快到了
这杯就特别适合抽造的收盒
这三杯就是我最喜欢的
K-O 可以养书果汁逃散
真的是又好喝
又健康
我一般是一周三四次换的喝
K-O健康的作息
能明显感觉到皮膚有变好
这外身体也变得非常的清零通唱
得脸透亮了
眼睛也是亮亮的
然后我总结了一些注意事项
我放在评论区了
你们可以试试
可以告诉我你们最喜欢哪一杯的味道